- Terrassée par la COVID-19
depuis 10 mois, la docteure
Anne Bhéreur peine encore
à marcher. Elle était
pourtant une grande marcheuse.
- Je marchais vite.
Actuellement...
Je parcours 150 m...
aller-retour... dans ma ruelle,
Les bonnes journée quand
je peux.
C'est une vingtaine
de minutes.
Puis, je suis fatiguée.
- La docteure Bhéreur
a contracté le virus en
décembre dernier, alors
qu'elle travaillait au front,
dans un CHSLD durement touché
par une éclosion de la COVID-19.
10 mois plus tard, la fatigue et
des troubles de la respiration
l'affligent toujours, mais ce
qui la fait le plus souffrir...
Dre ANNE BHÉREUR, médecin,
atteinte de la COVID longue
- C'est le silence.
Le silence... sur la COVID
longue.
Et sur tous les gens
qui en sont affectés.
Ça, c'est encore plus
difficle à accepter.
VIOLAINE COUSINEAU, prof. fran.
atteinte syndrome post-COVID-19
- On se sort la tête
du sable, s'il vous plaît!
Puis, on s'organise pour
que tous les malades partout
au Québec puissent avoir
accès à des soins.
- Accompagnés du collectif
COVID STOP, des malades et des
scientifiques crient à l'aide.
Ils demandent à Québec de créer
un réseau de prise en charge
des patients atteints
de la COVID longue durée,
en leur offrant
des soins spécialisés.
Dr AMIR KHADIR,
microbiologiste-infectiologue
- Si on laisse échapper ça,
ça veut dire qu'on se prépare
à une véritable épidémie
d'invalidités chez
des milliers de gens.
- Quand on lui a demandé
ce que Québec comptait faire
pour ces milliers de patients,
François Legault semble
avoir été pris au dépourvu.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Je suis pas au courant
du détail. C'est du cas par cas,
mais il faut s'occuper
des patients qui ont la COVID
longue, qui ont des effets
à long terme et on a bien
l'intention de s'en occuper.
- D'ici à ce qu'elle prenne
du mieux, Anne Bhéreur peut
compter sur l'aide de
ses proches pour l'aider
dans ses tâches quotidiennes.
- C'est très dur.
Je garde espoir.
- Et croit fermement que
la science et surtout le temps
lui permettront de retrouver
un second souffle.
Ici Jérôme Bergeron,
Radio-Canada, M